[Music]
all right i don't know the order of
these videos coming out but earlier
today in the day
i mentioned that bart reminded me of
an article we're about to talk about and
this is it so
you brought up talking talking to your
mother-in-law
about like sex and stuff oh yeah it was
kind of weird
and then i mentioned how i'm like well
it's not the same thing as this but it
reminds me of it so this story here
it's a bizarre love triangle between a
75 year old woman
her 52 year old ex-son-in-law
and her family she's a real [ __ ]
now so her daughter's
ex-husband and her 56 year old daughter
yes
so wait and the daughter's involved well
she's the first
daughter no that's the triangle no not
not the guy's [ __ ] both
oh okay the triangle is going this way
well here's the situation
he's in the middle of the pyramid i
thought it was all in the same room
that's a three-way right okay oh that's
a birthday party all right so
the beginning of this story it it's
where the ex-son-in-law he met
his wife the daughter in prison
and he was in prison maybe she was a
jailer
maybe she was working in a prison uh
yeah well
the reason why he went to prison just in
case you're curious is that
he killed his former employer over
unpaid wages
oh okay well just that okay and so and
then so when he was behind bars
he posted a dating ad to the local
newspaper and that's when
elena the daughter responded to it and
the two hit it off and they ended up
tying the knot
in the prison where he was being held at
the prison chapel how romantic
yeah and then three years later he was
released
and then so he moved into her home this
all takes place in russia by the way
and so even better yeah and so quickly
their marriage fell apart
and then that's when apparently the mom
is caring apparently apparently
the mom is claiming that the daughter
had cheated on her husband
shortly after his release and so the
daughter
kicked out the husband and so because he
didn't have
anywhere else to go the mother-in-law
took in the
she took them in all right all of it all
the way in hell yeah
so she told her daughter that her
husband's cheating on her
no told the husband that the daughter
was oh well she
i don't know if she informed the husband
at all it was just that like as their
retail
as they were retelling the story that
the the mom is saying well my daughter
cheated on him he had nowhere to go so i
took him in
i didn't do it out of love it was i just
felt sorry for him
so as the time passed they ended up
getting closer
and they started having a relationship
intimate relationship and he's 50 and
she's 70.
23 year difference yeah the way that you
put it is what made me 75
50 52. have you watched the brittany
murphy documentary
i did i know we watched it together
who's that
who's britney murphy brittany murphy
actress right she passed away
treasure chest she's an eight mile is
that pretty much yes
she's colorless she passed away right oh
is she in eight miles
rolling with the homies
and then um and then she was in that uh
girl interrupted
i love during that one she was in the
i'll never tell movie whatever that's
the one yeah
when she passed away her husband and the
mom were like
sleeping in the same bed together yeah
oh that's right
oh her yeah she was hot right
yep she's also scorpius so we're
connecting she died of
she dated eminem and she's a scorpio
she dated eminem yeah after they were in
eight miles together do you remember
watching eight mile
i was when did it come out i was in 2003
yeah i was 13.
i remember that sex scene though i was
like oh my god my pants are hot
was it that good it was like real it was
like there was no
music or romance to it it was just like
he banged her in his workplace like
behind these blockers and it's like
oh that's real that's right
you ever see that george clooney movie
three kings no it opens with george
clooney like raw [ __ ] some reporter
chick and i was like
damn that's how i want to force the
original sin oh
angelina jolie and antonio banderas oh
my god that was like oh
look my introduction to sex i'm like
damn he's pounding her what [ __ ] yeah
it's a long
really they cut it for the dvd version
but
the extended version you could see the
whole thing
anyway back to the story so
i know what i'm watching all right so
then
i like pretty woman pre-one six is there
a sex scene
not really a lot of bathtub scenes
though there's a lot of fade
to black yeah which in first oh true
they cut to a lot of candles
i was like in elementary school when
that happened so lots of shopping
yeah what's with that she's a hooker she
never hooks in the whole [ __ ] movie
that's her first hooking i know it sucks
though
anyway back to the story so remember the
love triangle with the
with the mom and the okay so
anyway disgusting they're probably so
ugly they ended up getting married
whoa the mom the mom and the son-in-law
yes yeah [ __ ] this mom she's probably
always jealous of her daughter or
something
what did she sabotage the relationship
because she wanted him for her probably
well the thing is the mom hold on the
mom is
roll the r you called her you called her
a pair
you're like [ __ ] pear sopela
[Applause]
it's like i'm waiting to get my hair cut
right now this is how my haircut place
is you're just jealous because you don't
work
that's what i'm saying i'm like i wish i
knew what they were talking about oh
okay i'm stupid
a story then yeah okay
so anyway back to this so then um okay
so the the mom is claiming that the
daughter i'm telling you joe
i'm listening mom is claiming that the
daughter is trying to sabotage
their marriage by getting the daughter's
daughter from another marriage what
technically
the granddaughter my daughter the
granddaughter to come and seduce
how old is this granddaughter soap opera
i know
he's the luckiest guy in the world yeah
what's with this guy he gets three
chicks
this is an entanglement who is this guy
he gets to [ __ ]
20 year olds to 70 year olds the
daughter
the the granddaughter is 30. but yeah
he's got the best of both worlds
and they're russians they're probably
hot three [ __ ] all of them trace
worlds
we don't i don't know i don't know if
he's the granddaughter was like yuck
and like but they're like come on do it
yeah he didn't take the bait
probably so well i like them older they
always take a bit
it got to the point where uh they
were 30 you're like a baby two years ago
they were planning to have a baby
together
and they even found a surrogate mother
this is the son-in-law
and the the mom right i was like how's
that even possible was his dick so good
because he murdered people like can we
not are we forgetting he murders maybe
sometimes murderers make the best
[ __ ]
dude they get a lot of fans in prison
yep like there's a bad boy
thing going on or something where people
write them letters and [ __ ] ted bundy
so then uh the surrogate the surrogate
mom that they found
they like she ended up scamming this
couple she took their
one million rubles payments um she ended
up did getting pregnant by the way
by him did he [ __ ] her but a dna test
showed that the baby was not
uh the the mom or the son-in-law they're
gonna check it was bull rats
yeah i don't know wait the baby was not
the mom or the son-in-law
uh you know how we're referring to the
grandma here as a mom
that's what i mean like it's nobody
whose baby was it it ended up being the
surrogate's mom
kid with someone else but she just took
the money gotcha yeah
and didn't even like actually go through
with their guy named boris
probably so then they ended up going on
to
the fact that this son-in-law once made
the mistake to look for another woman
but then that's when uh the mom the
grandma
ended up like forgiving him and just
continued the relationship
so can't resist that there's this whole
entanglement
he's still [ __ ] he's got so many
girls so
many girls you tell me okay here we go
finally oh
finally so this is the one this is the
daughter
the mom they look very similar yeah they
are very similar looking
the daughter is like the same age
no she looks older there's not that much
difference it's fascinating 75
56 i think it was 56. so he's the he's
the russian playboy huh
you never know the mom could have some
really good bj techniques
yeah good bj skills he's like oh what is
this that's what i'm saying
this is wonderful dude she puts [ __ ]
lube in her and like takes her
in her mouth why do they all purse their
lips like that
just the russian way maybe maybe they're
in they were saying something in russian
dude i realized i'd do this face a lot
what really yeah what's that
first your lips yeah or like i bring
this down a lot
hot how do you do that i can't do it on
commands i just ended up
like i noticed i noticed that i end up
doing it this one's like yo
the blues clues guy grew up he's like
hey you haven't seen the blues clues
guys lately here's what he looks like
now
he's bald is he really steve is bald
steve burns is or whatever
remember when everyone thought he died
yeah a bunch of times it was like he got
hit by a car it's crazy
like he overdosed on cocaine what i
didn't hear any of this yeah there's
tons of stories about how he died and
then he's like yo i'm still alive
oh and they're like no we don't care
it's just way better when you're dead
didn't that happen to koopa good and
junior too it did i remember that one
yeah i remember that it sounds like he's
living a pretty sick life here
this guy yeah he gets like the whole
family yeah
all in the family and he gets taken care
of he's living at her place
it's just so much drama dude i hate
drama so it sounds like a soap opera
seriously is it a drama to him so but
the baby was in the horse
and that was the surrogates everyone's
like hey we should send her to [ __ ] him
and he's like no
don't do it no please oh i had and the
granddaughter was like but i have to
yes he's like no please no please don't
do that she's not doing my belt oh no
every time he's with a woman she's like
i forgive you you are just a man
so they're saying here how um
the daughter or the mother
no the main mom the grandma she's
convinced that her like i said that her
daughter
is trying to sabotage their relationship
with her hot daughter
with her sexy granddaughter they also
add that her apartment is also a steak
and so as her husband this dude
would inherit her home as soon as she
passes
there it is which is something that the
family cannot accept
i apartment beach you promised that to
me
yeah in st petersburg oh i heard that
city's
crazy expensive because there's so many
like russian billionaires that
that makes sense in st petersburg and my
friend was at a hotel there and then he
was like
i wanted some burgers and fries and they
said it cost a hundred bucks and he said
what [ __ ] this [ __ ] and he went across
the street and got a six-pack of beers
a hundred none of this story makes sense
he didn't want to eat any russian food
though like why
american like no no because he was down
uh at the at the restaurant in the hotel
and he was looking at the menu and he's
like
what the [ __ ] i just want a burger and
fries it's like a hundred bucks
it was probably like the cheapest thing
on the menu yeah if you're such a
tourist she's like give me the russian
food yeah give me the i forgot what it's
called already but it is gross this
redfish
herring don't try that that's probably
why you probably do
a red hair i just want a burger like it
was like a herring a red herring in a
movie is like a it's a thing
oh yeah it's a thing it's a spy it's a
fake app
it's a thing it's a fake app in an
argument it's also a thing right the red
hair
the red hair it's like it's a mislead
yeah
you think this is the bad guy but it's
actually this oh that's what happened
when we ate the airport food
you're like that was the right answer
alleged to the bathroom it was you
thought it was a good guy
it was bad yeah
[Music]
you